[Music]
so
[Music]
gonna take
[Music]
what does it even mean to miss the rains
down in africa
the lyrics are i bless
rains down in africa
what
no they're not
uh yes they are
it makes even less sense
well i should know
because i karaoked it at my wedding
ah well i must have missed that
i was in the zone tearing it up on the
dance floor
you can't dance to save your life anyone
ever tell you guys you bigger like a
like an old married couple she's my work
wife
back to work rookie
[Music]
i would like to thank you for spending
your honeymoon in space with us it was
either space or italy
[Music]
italy doesn't beat
this race
[Music]
what the hell is that
markus
[Music]
orcas
how are you
okay hang on
marcus marcus come in
marcus
marcus damn it
come on
[Music]
marcus
i'm gonna get you home
you know without electronics we're gonna
need to make split-second calculations
up there
plus we lost our flight engineer
no
no no no guys
i'm not cleared for this well i'm the
acting director of nasa so
i just cleared you
congrats
yeah but
i've got ibs
irritable bowel
syndrome get motion sickness too you
said you always wanted to be an
astronaut
i have debilitating anxiety okay see if
the moon really is what you think it is
we're gonna need a mega structurist
[Music]
moon can pull us the rest of the way
casey can we do it
come on buddy
and gravity we do it oh i don't know go
for srv separation
completed
[Music]
get rid of it
right
we're going so slow
come on come on
uh
you could have just turned it off
okay
[Music]
i got it i got it
[Music]
[Music]
if you're watching this thing you know
by now a huge problem is heading our way
an emergency meeting is being called our
usual place immediately three bagels
i've made a shocking discovery
i needed to get me in touch with nasa
immediately well nasa and i aren't
really on speaking terms these days well
that'll change
when you tell them that the moon is out
of orbit
there's no need to panic i'm not facing
why are they lying about all this
it's too late to stop
you knew all this was happening before
nasa
you're the unidentified source oh yes
we're dealing with an intelligent entity
we're planning a mission to attack this
thing i'm asking you for your help
say yes brian
i needed to be brave
if the moon really is what you think it
is
suit up
you have got a big gravity weight coming
your way you have to launch now did he
say gravity wave
trouble
we're underwater guys
uh
that's crazy
what's the plan save the new and save
earth
ray what are you doing
let's find itself
wait for it
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
it's on airplane mode
[Music]
[Music]
you